tweet that it happened so yeah oh yeah
you know
every flip
this is so awkward all right
oh this is pretty cool though this
little stamp thing
nicki minaj you wanna talk about what
we're doing here
yeah we were uh gonna shield for the new
release and show uh the great metrics of
zero eight ten compared to zero eight
nine
but uh it seems like we're having some
uh technical difficulties and we thought
we'd uh we'd
loop you guys into the technical
difficulties you know this is part of
our life here so
in the uh in the interest of
transparency you get to see us uh trust
the staged intro plan but we did have a
next step
is there any metrics that do work that
are interesting well i mean the ones
that are really interesting the ones
that we were going for is uh these ones
here uh turn cutting's always been an
issue with uh with open pilot especially
in laneless mode and we've had some
fixes recently
that uh significantly improved that so
basically it's just an adaptive
weighting that if the mall is very
certain and you're cutting a turn that
is more aggressive in correcting when
the model is certain
um and we had some metrics that proved
how much better this was in 0x10
which is the ones we're trying to fix
now but really there should be a very
noticeable improvement in the turning
behavior when you're driving blameless
laneless keeps getting better
so hopefully zero
i don't know if that's is that good all
right what do we got is it gonna work
or this
yeah oh there we go all right so let's
let's compare these two so here you can
see turn cutting on left turns on
average you're three centimeters too far
inside the turn and right right turns
that's 1.5 centimeters and this is for
zero a10 so this is what's about to go
to release and then if we look at at
master you can see that's more than
twice as much so we're really getting a
pretty significant improvement in uh in
turn cutting on laneless
sweet that's something great to look
forward to
awesome like some nice mattress car the
dm stuff too i think people think we
ignore dm a lot do we want to look at
the dm metrics i think we should just
show them let's check them out everybody
yeah it's pretty important
are these is it this tv yeah this tv now
you can see here some things i think the
alert ones are pretty cool yeah how
often people get distracted alerts the
differences between night time daytime
difference between coma two comma three
cool stuff three percent of users got at
least a hundred yellow or red alerts in
over the last week that's pretty cool
should we show them try it too on the
yeah
we can try it on here right yeah yeah
look like you wanna
try to oh we got more of a mix bringing
up more and more metrics
whoa look at this we got another graph
here it's a graph it shows this is uh
it's just a distribution of the rh
deltas
uh in left and right turn so this is
left and this is right
right this is for master look for uh so
this isn't going to have changed right
yeah it wouldn't change much a little
yeah so this is the bias that's uh
caused by by the roll because the turns
are always banked into the turn um so
once uvek is done with the rule
compensation project so it should be uh
go inside together
nice what do you want to say just go on
comma.i
don't have any questions you want to
enhance the size of it like
200 hope
all right everyone new new thing george
talked about it on on discord but
it's live and real
you can now try comma two and upgrade to
a comma three within 90 days just pay
the difference the try two
try two programs try a two program so uh
yeah over here on this new page comma
dot ai slash compare we have uh both of
the products we sell
we have the price differences here
and underneath uh this is my favorite
part i wrote this i wrote modified phone
in a case
it's true comma three purpose-built
hardware uh it goes over just some tech
specs and the differences between them
and uh i actually probably need to make
this a little better but comma three has
nav
so it's pretty exciting
it should be like the
uh new you know
yeah
uh so those are the differences there's
24 more dragons
that's what i'm telling you it has
has the ssd
more pixels
on the screen and it's an oled
yeah comma 3 is a huge upgrade people
know that and that's why the next
section is what the community thinks
there's a bunch of people's quotes from
discord uh so we're not making this
stuff up this is what people are saying
about their comma three purchase
red acid trust red acid
master branch is glorious right now
triple x clam or apple
wait who's in the bill of the day is
there that's just the deal it's just
referencing that it's the nobel of that
game oh i see
yeah
let me leave him
yeah so
that's a short and sweet
seems like a no-brainer to me someone
just said in chat i agree
uh so yeah just open up this first uh
try to
talking about it all right go to how it
works and uh open up this
so yeah check it out all you gotta do is
uh purchase a comma two
if you like it do nothing
if you wanna upgrade to a comma three
keep going
there's a new discount code for the
comma three
three for me this code gives you the
price off that you paid for
the comma two
and then yeah you just send your comma
two back to us keep your harness and
everything set up and uh yeah we'll ship
you a comment three once it comes back
so all the details are on this page but
i think this is really great for new
users who don't necessarily want to pay
everything because they have never tried
open pilot before they don't know if
it's worth this much you'll find out it
is worth this much once you try a comma
two and check it out for yourself
anything you want to add about the try a
two program
adi but i know you think it's a good
that's a great program program hopefully
gets people into comma threes or just
for the ecosystem in general yeah i
don't know what else uh what else do i
just say
it should be a nice entry point in the
whole ecosystem
exactly
oh okay we have something to the program
it's exciting no i think uh that's it
real cost
all right so look
not enough people are buying common
threes that's that's that's real talk
right we're making a little bit more
money with threes than we made with twos
but that's obviously a lot less units
sold
um
so you know
we need a way for new people who are
like oh that's expensive to come in and
buy it try it too
if you don't like the two send it back
in 30 days as well yeah free
free
you know it's like nothing bro like get
in get in
um
yeah yeah
so we got oh fundraising's over so you
know if you're like you sent an email
today like oh i want to be a part of
kama's fundraising round i'll see you in
three years
[Laughter]
all right yeah so try it too it's gonna
be great do you want to check out the
internet longitudinal sure let's see the
moz
i think george
[Music]
all right how about we do the mazda real
quick and we're back in five minutes and
then we do intent on students
all right
so uh let's
go check out the monster are we gonna
check out the monster yeah we're gonna
go for a driver we're just gonna check
we'll go for a quick
test drive of it probably that has a
minimum uh steering speed
all right let's go let's check it out
let's check it out
all right
here it is
a mazda
all right we're going in
we got a real clean install from nick
yeah look at this nick's always the
professional
installer i'm sitting on a laptop
i'm getting a comma prime in here a lot
no print no prime i couldn't afford it
it's a nice interior yeah it's pretty
it's like a better rav4
yeah it's it's smaller isn't it it feels
a little smaller
uh but yeah this is the first uh monster
right but well we have other walls are
supported but uh this will be the first
one that's not in dash cam only mode
yeah and so for those who don't know
there's a bunch of mazdas that are
in dash cam only mode and the reason
it doesn't like that corner it's the
same corner we cut out last time oh
really yeah
everyone's saying f
we're back
i think we're back yeah i think we're
back why didn't youtube make this more
clear i know
it it showed up a prompt that's like do
you want to reconnect yes or no
i said yes
[Laughter]
all right yeah we're back uh so yeah i
was just saying there's a bunch of
mazdas uh in dash cam only mode and the
reason they're in dash cam only mode is
because you have to keep constant
steering torque on the wheel but yeah
with this newer mazda you don't have to
do that so we can make it uh yeah you
know 2021 cx-9
yes pretty nice
yeah thanks shout out to jakar he's uh
one who did the mazda port he's brought
in all the cars so far
um and he's the one that found out this
one doesn't have a lockout yeah and he
owns it himself yeah he even switched
once he found out it didn't have a
lockout he uh upgraded his car and he
got one of these great cx-9's oh he's in
here oh he's in there he said yay oh
nice
yeah thanks for all the hard work jakar
um he's a really high quality port he's
got firmware query in there i think it
was our first brand to be the only uh
only have firmware query maybe it was
volkswagen but i think it was mostly i
think it was monster yeah yeah
got rid of all the canned fingerprints i
mean it was a little easy because we
just deleted them all because dash cam
[Music]
yeah great work
yeah we're just fixing up a couple of
bugs uh we ran someone to verify him but
i don't know it's a very beepy car it is
beeps for everything
whoa just engage
nice
yup
hands off
look at that
oh and then it beeps we gotta fix that
oh yeah so we're gonna make it real nice
before we uh we give it back to the
rental company but
when this ship's in zero at 11 you'll
have a great experience
on your cx-9
um yeah it's standard on all trims right
i believe so yeah yeah that's great we
already saw the harness for it so that's
easy too it's the same as the fca
harness we lucked out there
same exact harness yeah so if you have a
pacifica which uh you know i don't think
has the greatest open pallet support
you
can straight up to a cx-9 keep the same
harness
yeah whenever you interact with it oh
interesting we gotta fix the beep yeah
i mean the steering's quite smooth is it
like honda kind of steering where it's
like smooth and and everything yeah
we're approaching a turtle it's more
similar to see how it looks the hyundai
steering wheel
oh that's good
but uh that's nice yeah here's your cars
working on longitudinal support too oh
nice that's gonna be great
yeah how's the torque and your
experience uh we've only had it
for less than a day now but the torque
seems pretty good i haven't gotten all
that many drives but nice yeah i mean it
seems good better than a cord
way better than me
the cord isn't that bad though
yeah
the problem with the accord we've been
talking about this is that it beeps when
it doesn't need to beep a lot
so that's something we need to work on
yeah it's like
it makes a lot of turns but it beeps i
also found with this car that this car
faults the eps a lot
[Music]
so we found that the the red alerts are
super annoying on steering available
we're gonna get that fixed for zero at
11. um
i know certain people have complained
about it quite a bit
um and we fixed it for the toyotas but i
guess
it faults more on these cars so we'll
fix it once and for all
we're really trying to work on the uh
reducing open pilot's uh
rough edges project your car said i
fixed the chime but it deep doesn't like
my fix no no we're gonna fix it properly
we're gonna get all the dash alerts in
there
how's the longitudinal seems pretty nice
yeah the launcher is pretty good
does an alert come up when we go below
the steering limit yes nice
oh
sweetie some traffic here
oh yeah it's a really nice car so i'm
sure you know some someone out there
watching the stream maybe one of you has
one we have quite a few moss users
actually last time i checked
yeah here's the alert
oh yeah
oh then there's that speed uh speed too
low alert and that's stupid too because
it doesn't tell you what the actual
minimum speed is oh really yes we'll get
that fixed up too
nice can't get too close
traffic this will be good for n10
longitudinal probably yeah
stay tuned for that we just gotta get
back to the office now in traffic
um but yeah how do you verify a brand
port how do you go about
oh there's a real user question but oh
there's jason uh nice
representing
canada do stop and go it's doing stop
and go right now it doesn't steer
unfortunately
yeah oh well
uh we'll flip this way yeah
yeah uh how do you verify a brand port
like we got this car we rented it what
is that yes what does that entail i mean
the first part is driving it around so
we found a couple bugs um
right off the bat like it doesn't always
cancel
oh that's a pretty big no-no we gotta
fix let's try to get in here
um
the blinkers were wrong and it's like
this stuff isn't necessarily the fault
of the maintainer
yeah
oh these guys are so nice they left like
two people in nice
this car's beeping there's a very beepy
car it's like the sonata yeah
um
well yeah so we found a couple bugs
right off the bat but i think this is uh
a lot of the problem is we don't
communicate
it's what the openpilot experience is
super well um
and
i think we're gonna try to do a better
job of this now
we launched our docs page it's gonna be
at docs.com.ai um that's gonna be the
documentation for developing open pilot
as opposed to the wiki where it's uh
very hand hold to kind of help getting
started um we kind of want to move away
from
i can even move away from that but we
want to segment off the development
documentation away from that kind of
stuff um
and
build out our documentation a little
more um find a used compatible car
oh these are
there's internal conversations
cheat this card that works with comma
someone asked if honda's still the best
i think hyundais are are the best well
those are pretty good they're pretty
good every car is every car has its own
quirks
i don't think there's one car that's
just like is perfect in every single way
yeah but
i don't know
architecturally the toyotas are still
very are still the cleanest uh yeah
but uh
i don't know i feel like a lot of cars
are a good choice yeah see this alert
this needs to
tell you the minimum speed i don't know
what the minimum speed actually is i
think it's 20 miles an hour that's
annoying you can't engage yeah and it
just sets the speed to that that's super
annoying
um um
but yeah so for as far as a brand port
though a lot of the work we do is is
kind of fixing those things that we
don't communicate super well and then
the other part is verifying the safety
so we do injection testing um we go
through all the panda safety and make
sure it works properly
um and that kind of stuff
so
that's what i'll be doing later half of
today right now i'm fixing up all those
little things like um just merge the pr
to fix the blinker states
so now
when you the convenience blinker works
and then it's not tied to the lamps
anymore you'd see like the lane change
alert flicker oh really yeah
and it's like if you haven't driven
another car it's hard to tell um or even
just from reading the code it's hard to
tell what the these things are supposed
to be
so we're really going to try to fix that
up um i can make this stuff better yeah
jakarta said 32 miles an hour
there's your car's in here
man
that's going to be hard to get up to 32
miles an hour
how do you use this and stop and go you
just engage
[Laughter]
that's like the weirdest limitation i've
ever heard of
because like you want to use it in stop
and go but you have to get all the way
up to 32 to make it work and stop and go
oh well
yes what else do the people want to know
the paddle
hell oh eric just said pedal
yeah what else do you all want to know
about you know brand ports and uh
our new documentation stuff i'm pretty
excited about it it's looking really
cool
we'll have some proper developer
documentation for open pilot
i mean i think that
what deployed uh this morning i think is
really
about discoverability right
and it's just kind of hard to find stuff
right now but if you go to i'm not sure
if it's up at docs.com air but if you go
to docs.aks.com.ai
you can see it there
and it really shows you all the
documentation we have um at least that's
in the pilot repo
um whereas it's not super easy to
discover it right now
we kind of get caught up in the way that
we learn open pilot or at least when
like new employees come you just kind of
up around the code base but this is
kind of a big ask for somebody who just
found your repo
and uh let's start poking around in it
you know cloning open piles actually
takes quite a long time we're gonna fix
that too
and we don't know anything about
specific i can engage at zurp you think
you need zero
is there anything that's going to be a
limiting factor going forward
a single panda was a limiting factor now
we have multipanda we're gonna merge
that vr
yeah that's exciting
multipanda is cool if if you have like a
car like there's a few nissans where the
the longitudinal
like control is on a different bus and
we ran out of buses so you can have two
pandas hooked up and and get
longitudinal working that way i know
robay's doing that for his uh tesla ap2
model s he has two pandas
so he can do longitudinal control um but
also you know that means you can support
the red panda and
yeah run it simultaneously with the
built-in
dose
on the comma three
dose
does community support cars have to tune
longitudinal per car every car is too
everything yeah yeah it's all good yeah
i mean all the tuning is kind of
community though yeah
though uh shout out to i don't know the
promised name quad miss i think oh yeah
the first real tuning pr yeah we got a
nice tuning pr you put all the plots in
there
um the volt was used to be the worst car
hopefully with zero 10 this has changed
and we're gonna start releasing metrics
on this
um
and we'll we'll make like a nice
document every release maybe of how open
piloty is your car yeah um and then you
know you'll be motivated you'll know
that your honda i don't know clarity or
whatever honda fit yeah how to fit a
ship car and you know you should we say
that um you should uh fix the turning
yeah yeah
we're we're 27 miles an hour we're
getting close
and almost engaged
yeah making our way back to the office
then we're going to check out in 10
longitudinal some updates there pretty
exciting yeah stay tuned after the
commercial break
oh we're so close
and then that could have been a
commercial break yeah well let's just
reiterate try it too for all those yeah
all those new entering the stream yeah
you want to do that yeah so
oh we're back we got it to engage woo
oh we're about to drop below oh no
yeah i mean at least we're
we're half
half all right
oh well
um
so yeah try a two new program check it
out just go to common.ai it's right on
the top there's a banner what it is
is uh
you want to try open pilot on your car
but you're like man i've never tried
open pilot i don't even know if it's any
good i don't want to spend 2 200
to just try it out so now you can buy a
comma 2 try it out for up to 90 days and
any point within those 90 days you're
like man open pilot's great i think i
should get a comma 3. uh you can just
like trade it up pay the difference so
it's a really cool program it lets you
just try out open pilot also of course
every product on our shop has a 30-day
return policy so
you could also just buy a comma three
and if you don't like your return within
30 days that this is what we're trying
to fix
we missed the alert but it was red
was it because you touched it oh yeah i
think it's because the override
i mean a lot of cars faults a lot of the
eps falls when you override right yeah
it also seems to fall for a little bit
longer yeah
so
that's gonna be great you can literally
go in the shop today buy a comma two
nothing special about it just uh buy
regular comma two once you buy a comma
three use the the code three for me and
uh you get that amount off then you just
have to send the comma two back to us
and uh yeah that's it we'll send you
your comma three yeah you guys are
really happy with comma threes they're
uh they're a real consumer electronic we
worked really hard
to make them nice yes
the common tunes are you know they drive
your car but the commentary is nice um
and it'll grow with you
you'll see all this nice new open pile
functionality
yeah that's very exciting
for those who don't remember like the
comma two
used to not be good at all when it came
out it was a cool world it was great it
ran away
yes it was good
yeah it was good for zombie zero seven
one we we've opened pilots a lot better
now we have assisted lane change oh look
at this oh we hit torque limit we did
this really well yes you're going too
fast there we go this is this is a
torque limit
roughly oh i think we're leveling out
that's not it's better than a cord but a
nice bang turn here maybe that has some
announcements around that
yeah you can tell because we're so
slanted on the screen because the
stabilizer stabilizes just to
what perfectly straight is i should show
some lane
this guy's not changes
uh yeah we gotta get over one more
it's really a lot of traffic today
someone said hardware costs money
yeah unfortunately it does it costs us a
lot of money too yeah
we gotta gotta make all the hardware so
we do have a lot of comma twos available
so
you know try it out see how you like it
i think it's gonna be great for all
those people who used to be trying comma
twos and uh that's how they got into the
ecosystem now you can keep doing that
and you still have the opportunity to
get a call that's so bad
we're also working on new sounds for
those of you who don't know the new
sounds are gonna be great i know some
people complain about the new sounds
that are in that ranch and complaining
they're not coming to the coma too
that's a work in progress branch it's
it's not steering it's kind of annoying
um
yeah we're working on new sounds
our sound guy's killing it um yeah that
sounded really good look how white i
look
yeah
um so hopefully those none of the sounds
are as annoying as that um
the new sounds are actually quite a bit
more pleasant um yeah
why is this still show up we're over 28.
yeah actually
oh there's probably some mystery stuff
um
well yeah what else is there to talk
about
i mean yeah let's try two is gonna be
great everybody go buy a comic 2 right
now if you have a supported car there's
really no reason not to and just uh give
it a shot see how you like open pilot
it's great
oh coma hack we're gonna talk about
comma hack yeah how's the ctf going
anybody's still doing it that's a good
question is anyone still doing the seat
yeah everybody play it and have feedback
yeah
let us know
logan said or just try a three
also true you could just try three
they're back in stock temporarily so if
you want one buy it now we might run out
of stock real soon
again
we were running a stock of comments
those are threes threes
oh we got comma twos don't worry
we're still waiting on screens
for what comma three yeah yeah
yeah
so uh we're stu someone said they're
stuck on six out of eight submit if you
haven't yeah if you haven't
i just like seeing all the submissions
we did give out all the prizes already
um
although there's one flag in there for
an extra prize and uh nobody actually
followed the instructions in that flag
it's really sad so if you did find that
flag and uh you don't obstruct
instructions i'm talking about update
your form and while we'll get your prize
sent out
because quite a few of you did find all
eight
how many common twos are left there's so
many and we're gonna be uh even making a
few more comma twos so
we don't just have what we have we have
even more comma twos that we're gonna
make
uh production's very excited we're gonna
do a comma two week one of these weeks
we're gonna mix it up
after building all common threes for
quite a while get back to the old the
old common twos
yeah
but uh yeah if you haven't done the ctf
and want to come to comma hack you'll
submit up until the event uh the event's
kind of full but you know if you do well
in the ctf
you can come
you can always use more good people at
the event
yeah
if you're a winner you're always
welcome there we go we're back
oh no
no more steering
no the comma 3 you can look at it with
sunglasses there's no issues it's
correctly polarized oh should we tell
them
about that yeah we could talk about that
yeah so uh in early production we found
out that uh
there was a lot of early issues with
those screens and uh we had to reject a
lot and we had to
we had to throw away a lot of screens
but uh and then at the end of all that
we found out that some of them are also
polarized wrong yeah what happened is
igor and i were looking at
comma threes and we're like this one
looks like blue the screen looks blue
when it's off so now it's like oh let me
just get a pair of glasses like
sunglasses and let's try it out let's
check out what's going on and then i
looked at the stress test and like half
of them were black with sunglasses i'm
like oh no i think that was right before
the first batch too it was right before
yeah the first batch was gonna be like
double the size it was but uh yeah
that's like we gotta reject all these
screens so we took them off uh rejected
them
all the screens coming out and common
threes are polarized the correct way
it's really nice i know that was a big
issue with the comma twos funny enough
like a lot of the monitors around the
office also are polarized the wrong way
if you wear glasses
um yeah isn't it weird oled displays are
polarized uh it looks like the
smartphone people do this so like you
can hold it vertically and it looks the
best
for glare so but that's wrong like if
if you're looking at a smartphone screen
like this
and then we mount it like this you got a
problem so
these are works great for your compiler
application
it's a nice screen yeah it's a great
screen and we have a designer uh in the
pipeline in the interview pipeline yeah
so hopefully we'll
be seeing some of his work in open piles
some new design yeah be awesome to make
use of that great screen
it's really beautiful anyone with a
combo 3 can attest to that and they're
all the same we calibrate them i know
they look exactly the same oh my god
jakar said i don't know where all these
uh loud beeps are coming from i don't
haven't gotten any of these wait really
yeah
you have this patched out or something
red alert
shields up
oh man what else is this car's probably
good for highway cruising i'd say that
yeah i'm sure it's great for highway
cruising it was
it was great when i was driving around
but there was no traffic earlier today
i mean
it's doing pretty well too do that yeah
jacar did a great job with the port
actually should we let's ask him for an
update how's longitudinal doing it has
longitude no can you work on that
ah good tomb yes
what
could that guy's hilarious
uh jakarta said um
he can engage at zero and he doesn't get
any of these issues he probably can't
engage at zero yeah
wait what's the difference yeah how do
we engage with zero
torque on the mazda is kind of like
better than the accord i'd say maybe
what do you think maybe it's probably
more than that let's see all those here
so we're gonna run 40 let's see
hey it's
that's
holding it
that's good i like when they hold it
yes
i had to click reconnect we're back
no one said f in chat this time so
maybe we didn't cut out who knows
how many people are watching
82 82.
mazda we got likes already can you get
likes on a live stream yeah 28. like
short f
short f welcome back
everyone give this video a thumbs up
let's get to 100 likes
we don't have enough people
for that but uh
yeah smash that like button
any other questions anyone has
anyone buy a comma two yet jakar the
blind spot stuff also doesn't work
it doesn't block the lane change
properly i haven't looked into it yet
good job said haha
oh he's watching yeah i don't understand
what your complaints are man do you
wanna you wanna clarify here
uh voacc
that's kind of tied in with end to end
longitudinal one send in longitudinal is
good enough to ship i feel like that's
when the oacc is coming out we're not
gonna
we're probably just gonna focus on
intent longitudinal
53 likes that worked it would dig double
amount of likes
i don't think i've ever liked a youtube
video ooh what are some of the hackathon
project ideas oh we got some cool ones
so uh we're thinking of doing a can fd
carport i think that's going to be
igor's project
that's awesome yeah red panda supported
multipath support finally in zero
um
it was ready for zero eight ten but uh
it just was not too close to the release
we couldn't merge it uh that close
um what else we got we want would be
cool somebody did a see-through comma
three so they track your head pose and
then they use the cameras on the back to
pass through like you're looking right
through it that'd be cool um we have
some uh maybe an announcement uh for new
hardware
at the
hackathon not a comma three yes not a
comma three s or a comma four
comma three forever
tell me three now we're already working
on the comma six guys
six cameras you six cameras
what else what are the projects we have
common security yeah we're thinking
common security we're finally thinking
about it i mean we've always thought
about it it's just you know less time
for calm security yeah wouldn't that be
neat if your car like got hit or
something like you guys bought open
again all right i got so lucky today
we got the 30 minute yeah
it's not actually 30 minutes
um yeah we got lots of cool projects
lined up a lot of common employees want
to do uh calm security stuff yeah we're
thinking streaming instead of the
snapshot feature and the snapshot
feature is pretty lame i think so it'd
be really cool if you can stream
comments it needs less power yeah we're
also going to work on that yeah comma
3.3
mark
[Music]
the comma and then you know four letters
can anybody guess it george might have
talked about it before yes he's you know
he's hinted at the thoughts
yeah but yeah yeah
coming to comma connect maybe after the
hackathon do you guys have hackathon
project ideas uh put it in maybe the ctf
channel
yeah we'll check it out we'll come here
no we're not going to parallel parking
can we say anything about the ctf for
the heck of that no
no comma four no it's not the con before
come on neck what do you guys wanted the
combo for though i'm curious
yeah comma three has like everything
you'd want right
got 360 vision
yeah
well it takes forever to yeah the
admission doesn't turn off it turns off
after a minute i don't i don't want to
do this it's super strange
what's the most commonly used vehicle
it's still previous by far by far yeah
there's the rav4
the corolla there's like one more toyota
someone said no screen
no screen the screen's beautiful
it's beautiful
all right george was on earlier yeah are
we ready to go in yeah let's go you'll
uh open the door yeah
cool all right everyone
moment you've been waiting for
and to end longitudinal
let's let's try it out
got some improvements since last time
when it basically didn't work at all
all
yeah it drives better than someone who's
been driving for a week maybe we'll see
harold it's time
look at all our boxes we have you ready
all right
no i mean
these are some parts of common bodies
uh common bodies are coming soon uh
you'll be able to attach your comma
three to your common body so like here's
a comma three
uh the other common bodies in there
being worked on but just imagine this
but a little narrower and like extend it
up to like we're going to make them a
nice five feet tall
you know should we sit on lumo
oh wow really fast
how do i spell
yes okay well so it's going to be
nothing like this we promise
when i see a lumo
i just want to kick it all right look i
just want to kick it right
and can you kick it yes you can right
like that's what i think but when you
guys see a comma body
it'd be like wow
cool um so you asked what can the common
body 2 do
and let's go for drive
uh because that's the wrong question
what's important is that if anything if
you can't see a stop sign or a stop
light that you mentioned comma pencil
[Music]
we stuck outside
now i got my phone
um
i've never tried antenna longitudinal
before
uh
the best it's ever been is it good
am i gonna be upset
i'm clear and unclear
oh my god am i going to like this or not
i think i'll go in the back apparel i
think i should go in the back like all
right
angles
it's the kama garage
all right
you put this in a cup holder somewhere
all right
we're in
i like parts of the experience
okay so i hope you feel the same way so
you're telling me the highways actually
was good
i liked the highway i thought it did
some some really smooth and impressive
things i like off highway it doesn't
click
it only opens with the button really is
that true has it been has it been an
illusion the whole time
i sit there i press the button it's on
like the sixth press that it closes wow
so here i'll give an introduction what
is n10 longitudinal someone's watching
this video for the first yeah so
end-to-end long-term in this in this
case it's really just doing what the
model wants to do what the model thinks
a human would do all right no lead cars
only play a very small role as like
limits everything else is really just uh
letting them all do what it thinks a
human would do oh wow
[Music]
wow it stopped at a stop sign all right
let's go good call good call bottles
[Music]
all right
we stopped
yeah sometimes it stays stopped
sometimes it goes um what would a human
do here all right let's go
uh see this is really where my pencil
can help i think why is common pencil
gonna help it though also the problem is
we only have a very narrow field of view
that the common thread oh they got to
improve the yeah
do those comma three labels all right so
we need to see we need to see the full
field of view for the all right well
so much for that stop sign
all right but hey two out of three eight
bags
yeah but so to use the full comma three
field of view we need the segment to
work on the full field of view because
that's an essential part of our offline
stack
um
and so comma pencil needs
i mean to be fair i'm not sure i would
have stopped at that stop sign either
i'm not sure that's a good excuse oh i
think they're lenses we're gonna clean
the lens too oh yeah look at a sturdy
dirty lens dirty lens sorry for the
weird bluetooth audio everybody all
right uh you want to clean the lens
before i engage actually it's fine it's
not gonna matter all right
we're going into some traffic all right
let's merge here
all right all right good good merge yeah
so it's much more aggressive than the
normal policy is because the normal
policy is quite wait so this is almost
entirely on tanned yeah pretty much all
right
and uh yeah it should uh
i mean yeah so it's a lot more
aggressive which is one of the nice
parts it really knows when to be
aggressive
we have very conservative limits in the
normal planner because otherwise we just
floor it when you really don't want it
to
but now it's really this is this is
really good i know it's impressive right
i mean this is like almost shippable if
it just didn't stop at stop signs
yeah i think really with the wider field
of view
you know it's really gonna be quite good
yeah big model looks like it's coming to
the comment three only who wants to
write the code to make it work on the
two i mean you guys can try
i don't know we're gonna do it
yeah just very exciting all right
looks like the lead thing is screwing up
here
yeah but that shouldn't really matter
for the policy it's really just doing
what the model wants to do so i've
noticed when it gets at low speed it can
really get quite confused
and then here
oh well i can't it can't this is why we
need the bigger box comma pencil
now the pencil
there's a bunch of common three images
in there oh yeah great yeah this is the
live end longitudinal brand yeah this is
ant and longitude that was a little hard
on the brakes
yeah every now and again it's a little
aggressive is that can we put an alert
if it's hitting the car policy
yeah we can yeah maybe just a little
individual an indicator if it's hitting
if it's using the car policy yeah yeah
because that might have been a car
policy based thing i don't know at least
i found on the hyundai it breaks way too
hard for the cars but it's probably
poorly tuned
um yeah the hyundai is weird
yeah like it like slams the brakes it's
super strange but the limits here are
much uh
they're much closer we just lowered the
following what do we set the following
distance still 75
oh
i mean that's still and it's also not
that tightly coupled most of the cost is
an acceleration from the model which has
nothing to do with the leads
yeah all right we're gonna let this guy
in model what do you think
there's no way you can see that
cobble
let's go
i don't know what i found really
impressive is just how smooth it is i
feel like in this stop-and-go it's more
smooth than uh
than
the normal policy
yeah i think this is pretty good
it just has much better awareness
all right we'll go back to the streets i
want to wait in this traffic
yeah
all right wait models should be able to
do that right drive aggressively it
should be drive aggressively
well now it's exciting
it's not going to floor it as much as it
usually would well this is maybe
but yeah this is something that really
annoys me the normal policy is that
it'll just shoot past slow moving
traffic which is completely unknown well
let's set it to something unreasonably
high and see what it does yeah i mean
it's not accelerating that much anymore
yeah yeah this is good this is good so
you see my max is 49 and we're going 34
right now we're gonna slow down for this
turn
i mean actually i probably wouldn't slow
whoa
oh wait what's going on there i want it
to go
oh it's slowing down for this one
actually i slid on for this one when i
drive this oh i really really like this
one here
oh yeah this is this merch
no i didn't mean to
merge i didn't mean to yeah we're in
corolla this is what the model wanted
this is what the model wanted it didn't
know i wanted to go home
[Music]
going to the office
wow that was good
that was really good
that felt nice
yeah that felt like it didn't feel like
it like oh i picked up the lead car oh
let me break aggressively
yeah no it's it's really it's showing
hints of
his human level of wow this is almost
shippable i know right now
like it's like almost like
we gotta figure i mean i think it slowed
down too much
yeah but enough in the office
check it out all right navigate on open
pilot let's
[Music]
yeah
i'm only eight minutes away
guys when we put in this
navigation
with the end to end everything yo that's
just called driving i think it's just
going to work wild field of view the
maps
i think that may have been stretched
where's that where's my keeps
oh look
slow down for turns
[Music]
that was cool
look at this guys
[Music]
just do it right
yeah
oh i guess that's not the ball's fault
well it kind of is that i don't know i
don't know about that
we're picking up speed that's probably
not
what i would do here because this is the
sharpest turtle
okay never mind
[Music]
how did it know
all right a pedestrian crossing ahead
okay the model couldn't even see that
i think i think we need to did you see
no the path was straight yeah i think
this model didn't train as well
laterally as oh
okay okay this is uh yes it's it's clear
that it kind of didn't the training's
still a little bit unstable to be honest
uh the longitudinal training what you
mean in the rl or though the yeah so the
joint simulator training where
translator among too long ah okay i'm
training one now that is stable uh but
that's gonna take another couple days to
get on the car yeah yeah watch we're
gonna make it faster
uh no be nice but it's not a requirement
ah well that's what i know how to do it
i make things faster
people keep saying this doesn't look
like it's shipping soon what do you mean
open pilot right now would just floor it
no matter what
wait if they don't think it's shipping
soon what are they saying they're saying
shipping soon in quotes
all right it's not checking out we won't
lie to you
we won't lie to you guys i just think
the trend of improvement since the last
stream we did with this has been very
very clear all right
let's put the speed absurdly high and
see if it goes absolutely fast
someone said this is as good as fpd yeah
i mean it kind of is
yo
everyone who wants this stuff needs to
lower their expectations like that's
cool look the speed's 55. it's not going
55. i haven't this is how i'd go yeah
it's hard catch up
nice
all right is it going to stop for this
green light like a tesla
whoa no
oh is it going to do that
that's not bad
nice
yeah
i don't know why it does this is like
very hesitant it doesn't like commit to
stuff that's 100
someone said i tried end-to-end long
today and it was super smooth and
stopped at a lot of red lights only
thing i noticed that it drove 10 to 15
miles below speed limit on summer oh
well this was the bug right
[Music]
now
too lucky we need a pencil well do you
think i just couldn't see that in time i
mean it was there right it should have
seen it that should actually be stupid
it was probably just a big snowball yeah
we're back
i mean to be fair like you didn't have
to slow down
did we do the math
i wouldn't trust it no
i'm just gonna stop there for a second
okay
i mean this is pretty chill right here
right like normally would like zip up
there and then
yeah i but the the first thing i see
this fixing is just not like floored
when there's cutouts yeah it goes super
fast next to slow moving traffic well
the really nice thing about the uh the
safety event and longitudinal
is um
is uh
we can leave in the car policy and we're
not going to remove the car policy but
it's just like a rail right and you can
like you can oh
what was that
all right
why these lights turn red notice by the
way how my speed is set to uh 57
yeah we're going like 25 it's pretty
good
[Music]
oh yeah
oh yeah it's time for red light yeah
nice
there's no is that in the box now
probably it wasn't
it's just new i think it just remembers
what do you mean it remembers how can it
remember whether it's green or oh
remember
a few seconds oh remember from a few
seconds ago it's just not like it's like
you know well we trained on the lights
and the time of day and
um wait this is so tesla quality right
here remember is wrong
it sees a lot of red lights up there
it's up no it eventually went i think
the car is moving next to it sometimes
that inspires you oh
all right you know this is a stop sign
right blinking red no it doesn't know
that
um
all right well
what are your thoughts
[Music]
it's about what i thought it would be
actually that's good yeah so it's a
tesla quality ship it
i mean it's tesla quality we don't we
don't we don't ship things
it feels kind of like msd although to be
honest i was more scared of the fsd car
at least the wheel isn't gonna jerk
exactly at least i know the lateral is
good
well actually not really it really
didn't converge
well if we can keep the trend of
improvement going from the last few
weeks
yeah i see a good path to shipping some
of these features one of the keys to
making this work was our simulator now
understands depths a bit more oh you see
just by habit i disengage in front of
the lights i don't remember that i can
just leave it on
smiled
yeah all right so and can we have some
maybe that's one of our benchmarks we
have to stop at 99.9 percent of lights
yeah something like that yeah
i think once it can see them it's really
good i think so too yeah like it's so
much harder a problem to remember yes
i imagine and yeah imagine you you know
we should we should ship
model goggles
put on your model goggles
be a model for a day and see how well
you can drive you know
then stop blaming open pilot like
let's park in the street we'll take this
to the office sounds good sweet
all righty great seems more promising
than 10.3
ah well you know
bars low
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah say bye all right yo
thank you for joining this stream uh
look i have very high hopes for 10
longitudinal we have we have almost a
depth net now
um
yeah
try to
oh try it too yeah
yeah uh look
if you
want a three but are like wow that's
expensive try it two and you'll be like
wow this two is so good that you'll buy
a three and instead of spending 21.99
you'll spend 10.99 and then another 1099
so it'll feel like it's only 10.99 but
two times
right have you guys ever seen those
commercials
with like you know when something's like
a hundred dollars on an infomercial but
they don't want to tell you so it's like
four easy payments of 25
yeah yeah it's like that but this is
just two easy payments of
10.99
um it doesn't read signs judges speed by
everything in the scene that's true uh
99.99 all right all right office crew
bye everybody bye should we show them
the new office
no yeah not yet
bye